你有沒有曾經去過某一間咖啡廳
覺得他們的咖啡很好喝
然後呢 你就興高采烈了買了豆子回家
但是回家沖煮後
卻發現在店裡喝到的
跟你在家沖的味道完全不一樣呢
原因是因為啊
咖啡的風味70%取決於豆腫
另外的20%呢 決定在烘焙
那剩下的10%
才是你能控制的沖煮喔
那單單這個10%啊
就會影響到的風味就占得非常非常大
所以今天就來教大家
如何透過幾個簡單的步驟
教你沖出一杯好咖啡
我是中備男子哈迪
我們一起來沖杯咖啡吧
在沖煮咖啡前
你一定會有個疑問是
該準備多少的咖啡粉
來沖多少CC的水
那這邊你可以記一個黃金比例是
1比10到1比16
在這個範圍裡面呢
我們可以沖出一杯濃淡度適中的咖啡
那怎麼叫做1比10到1比16呢
假設你今天準備10克的咖啡粉
你可以在100cc到160cc的水裡面
那這個都是一個安全的範圍裡面
就比較不太容易沖出難喝的咖啡
那抓好這個比例以後呢我們接下來要準備的是磨咖啡粉咖啡豆準備的研磨度呢大約可以比砂糖再細一點點大概是這樣的感覺那這個粗細度呢
是比較適合拿來做手沖咖啡的
另外還有手沖很重要的要素是
它的水溫也會影響到你的風味
水溫的話會建議初學者
可以抓85度C到95度C之間
都是適合來做沖煮的範圍
如果低於85度C的話呢
那到時候你沖出來的成品
你喝到的時候它可能水溫或過低
口感就不好
如果水溫太高的話呢
相對很容易沖出苦澀的咖啡
只要記得這幾個項目以後啊
接下來我們還有一個很重要的動作是
要先清洗它的濾紙
為什麼會建議大家洗濾紙呢
因為濾紙通常上面會有殘留一些脂味
那這個脂味呢
到時候會影響到我們對咖啡的風味
所以呢我們在沖煮之前
可以先用熱水
先由中心慢慢的向外畫圈
把濾脂完全的浸濕
進而把這個脂味完全的去除
那另外有一個好處是
當我在洗的過程中
這個濾杯跟下壺也會因為熱水的關係
同時被我做溫熱
在沖煮前呢還有一個動作很重要
叫做燜蒸
因為剛磨完的咖啡豆會帶很多新鮮的氣體所以可以透過像洗熱水澡的方式讓咖啡豆先清醒過來等等我們在萃取的時候咖啡的風味相對也會變得更完整一點但是悶蒸要特別注意一個項目是
它不是豪邁的把熱水完全灌下去就可以了
它需要一併的比例是
當你準備了多少咖啡粉
你把它乘以一倍
在它一倍的範圍裡面
把所有咖啡粉完全的浸濕
那我們今天準備的話
是18克的咖啡粉
總共充280cc
悶蒸一樣從中心慢慢向外畫圈
在他一倍的水量以內完成把所有咖啡粉都淨濕
由於乾膜完的咖啡粉會帶很多新鮮的氣體
初學者會建議稍微等待10到20秒鐘
讓他的新鮮氣體完全釋放後再繼續做沖煮
沖煮的話一樣從中心慢慢向外畫圈
畫到大約50元硬幣大小以後再回到中心點
重複這個動作有點像是在寫日文NO字型的方式
更像是我在輕柔的去攪拌咖啡粉
把它前面的酸感跟甜感更完整的去萃取出來
當水位到達一定的高度的時候
因為我們萃取的水量會比較多一點點
所以後段呢我們可以稍微停一下下改成單點的注水法這個當點注水法更像是我更輕柔的去攪拌這咖啡粉比較不容易把咖啡後面的色感一併的帶出來
當沖煮完以後你會發現濾杯上面會很多白色的氣泡
那這些通常都會是它帶有刺激感的味道
甚至是尾段它因為泡的時間過長了
所以相對的色感也容易殘留在這裡面
所以我們不要再等它流完的時候
就提前把它抽開來
最後尾段這個水
它會把不好的味道統統集中在這邊
我們就不要去影響它裡面咖啡的味道
最後沖煮完成還有一個動作很重要
記得要先均勻的搖晃攪拌一下
這樣它的風味才會是一致的喔
其實要沖煮出一杯好的手沖
相對的技術也是很重要的一環
所以大家在沖煮前
不妨先多練習一下是
單純用倒水的方式
用細細的水流
而且要穩定的出水
只要你穩定了以後呢
相對要沖出一杯好咖啡
就變得比較簡單囉
謝謝你透過視覺和聽覺
和我享受了一杯咖啡
如果你喜歡這杯咖啡
請記得訂閱和分享
支持我繼續創作更棒的作品
我是中飛男子哈迪
我們下次見囉
掰掰